[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à tous ravis de vous
retrouver ça vous regarde en version d
confiné c'est parti voici le sommaire
quand va-t-on enfin faire un geste pour
les premiers de corvée infirmières
caissière livreur éboueurs la nation
tout entière leur rendra hommage le 14
juillet prochain mais le sonnants et
trébuchants tarde à venir
comment mieux rémunérer les français les
plus modestes en première ligne durant
la crise qui doit mettre la main au
porte monnaie
faut-il revoir la répartition des
richesses on en débat ce soir avec deux
députés municipal faut-il revoter dès le
mois de juin elles ont tellement de
cette petite musique du côté des lits d
emmanuel macron voudra solder ce dossier
rapidement les socialistes et les
républicains lui mettre la pression pour
aller vite et c'est l'assemblée qui
pourrait trancher alors raisonnable ou
trop risqué on se pose la question se
soit enfin enfin le jour d'après le
numérique nouvel épisode de notre
collection d'entretien ce soir
l'économiste daniel cohen
elle nous alerte sur les dangers d'une
numérisation du monde à la faveur de
cette crise voilà ça vous regarde vous
avez le programme sans oublier la
chronique de thomas des prêts une
députée dans la tourmente j'ai nommé
laetitia abia ça y est cette forme ses
vêtements
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
bonsoir fiona lazard annonce merci
d'être l'âge physiquement en chair et en
os
il faut se le dire c'est pas si évident
parce que les députés s'habitue assez
aisément ses visioconférence vous êtes
député la république en marche du val
d'oise présidente du conseil national
des politiques de lutte contre la
pauvreté et l'exclusion sociale en face
de vous pierre dharréville bonsoir
bonsoir et bienvenue députés communistes
des bouches du rhône est derrière son
écran normalement il ya raphaël legendre
raphaël est ce qu'il est là c'est
normalement notre chroniqueur il est là
c'est un plaisir de vous retrouver même
derrière votre écran jour automnale est
journaliste économique à l'opinion et
chroniqueur dans cette émission ce soir
notre débat pourrait se résumer en une
phrase il nous faudra nous rappeler
aussi que notre pays aujourd'hui tient
tout entier sur des femmes et des hommes
que nos économies reconnaissent et
rémunère si mal voilà ça c'était le
président de la république emmanuel
macron le 13 avril dernier
depuis eh bien ces hommes et ces femmes
on les applaudit on leur donne de la
reconnaissance mais est ce qu'on les
rémunère à leur juste valeur c'est toute
la question aujourd'hui il y avait un
conseil des ministres pour justement
décidé qu on leur rendra hommage à tous
ces hommes à toutes ces femmes de 14
juillet prochain est ce suffisant
on en parle dans un instant mais celui
qui va nous planter le décor comme
chaque soir avec son ton et son regard
c'est stéphane blakowski depuis sud de
la france des femmes mais qu'elle est
belle cette bibliothèque je comprends
mieux pourquoi vous est si intelligent
vous avez tous lu ou pas du tout c'est
de la déco voyez c'est sur ces mots que
c'est mon style était renvoyé son côté
officiel par la bibliothèque
en tout cas c'est très impressionnant
tout sérieux l'appeler ya tout ça tout
ça si j'ai bien compris tout de suite
[Musique]
alors si j'ai bien compris ce soir
stéphane si j'ai bien compris myriam
pendant ce manquement on a tous pris
conscience que ce n'est plus utile à
notre social théâtre société pardon
était souvent ce qui était le moins bien
payé alors ça peut paraître injuste avec
que voulez vous c'est ce qui est prévu
par la loi
pas en tout cas par la loi du marché en
fait dans notre société
ce qu'on paye le plus cher c'est pas du
coup c'est utile c'est ce qui est rare
bon pour faire simple voyez un diamant
c'est beaucoup moins utile qu'un litre
d'eau mais comme c'est beaucoup plus
rare c'est beaucoup plus cher
eh ben pour les salariés c'est un peu
pareil je vais vous dire tout le monde
est d'accord pour dire que n'importe
quel infirmière de n'importe quel
hôpital public
elle est beaucoup plus utile à la
société que qui donnait mbappé oui mais
voilà il n'y a qu'un seul qui viennent
bape et notre titi national alors qu'il
a 300 mille infirmières dans les
hôpitaux publics alors vous me direz si
cette loi du marché elle est injuste bon
ben voilà il faut remettre en cause le
capitalisme
non mais franchement pas là je m'emballe
un peu mais c'est parce que ce soit
devenu un révolutionnaire exalté un même
bruno le maire le ministre l'économie
remet en cause le fonctionnement notre
économie on les écoute il faut un
nouveau capitalisme qui soient plus
respectueux des personnes qui soient
plus soucieux de lutter contre les
inégalités et qu'ils soient plus
respectueux de l'environnement à la
franchement il a l'air pas mal ce
nouveau capitalisme qui fait exactement
le contraire de l'ancien bon on a hâte
de la voir
en attendant le problème c'est que ben
les métiers tenues sont toujours aussi
mal payés en fait tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire que c'est injuste il
ya plus qu'un petit détail à régler
trois fois rien il faut juste savoir qui
va payer les augmentations alors
heureusement bruno le maire a une idée
il dit il suffit que les entreprises
augmentent les serbes a tout simplement
alors les patrons forcément sont
peut-être moins enthousiastes à cette
idée
d'autant que de son côté lille
gouvernement a promis des primes aux
soignants cinq cent mille 500 euros et
puis il ya un décret qui en parlait en
fait toutes les prises n'ont pas été
versés comme envoyé ce matin dans
certains titres régionaux
bon alors forcément c'est un point
inquiétant ce cafouillage et il ya lynx
inquiète beaucoup
c'est patrick mignola le patron du
groupe modem à l'assemblée
il a donné une interview dans le monde
d'hier je roule à lier ensemble voilà ce
qui l'inquiète
pour qu'un cataclysme social ne succède
pas aux attaques et de sanitaires dans
une forme de reproductions des gilet
jaune vient il est nécessaire de faire
un geste en direction des travailleurs
sous payés voyez en fait je me demande
si le meilleur argument pour que les
salaires pour que les études qu'ils
soient mieux payés c'est pas le bon
vieux mouvement social qui fait peur et
aux patrons et le gouvernement
bref à l'ancienne merci stéphane vous
restez avec nous pour intervenir quand
vous le souhaitez fiona nasa vous êtes
tous les deux j'imagine d'accord sur le
constat on a découvert avec cette crise
enfin on a découvert on le savait mais
ça nous a souffert les visages voilà ils
sont devenus visibles et on a
redécouvert ses diamants pour le coup
qui peuplent nos hôpitaux et dont nous
avons eu besoin en cette période de
crise sanitaire et pour lesquels
effectivement il faut que nous arrivions
à revaloriser et la fonction dans les
symboles c'est important mais pas que
des symboles les plus indispensables
sont les moins bien payés ou bien sûr à
l'est plus donc ça c'est insupportable
c'est le souk des changes bien sûr
sachant que ces métiers là sont souvent
des métiers très féminisé et on le voit
dans la première ligne comme dans la
seconde ligne
laissons les pros les professionnels
soignants mais aussi toutes les
caissières sont souvent des femmes et
beaucoup des personnes qui ont été
mobilisés sur le terrain qui ont dû
travailler pendant cette période de
confinement sont des femmes et des
femmes sous payés donc oui il va falloir
remettre un petit peu d'argent dans ces
métiers là du côté de l'état pour l'ailé
pour les professionnels soignants qui
sont la fonction publique hospitalière
pour les enseignants mais également les
entreprises on va venir aux solutions
parce que c'est pas simple parce qu'on
est dans une crise économique et que les
entreprises ont déjà beaucoup de
problèmes
on va essayer de voir ce que vous mettez
sur la table peut-être même que vous
pourrez vous mettre d'accord qu'il s'est
hissé sur le constat c'est à dire quand
même que moi je pense qu'on ne découvre
pas tout ça il ya eu un mouvement social
dans les hôpitaux pendant des mois et
des mois femmes et d'hommes qui
revendiquait
med pour leur situation pour la
reconnaissance de leur métier de leurs
fonctions enfin vie c'est pas nouveau
car tout ça nous avons déposé hier dans
une proposition de loi pour revaloriser
le smic qui a été examiné dans notre
niche parlementaire donc les inégalités
dans notre pays je sais pas qui les
découvrent en tout cas pas moi
stéphane le poing levé 10 au fond il
peut y avoir des convulsions sociales il
peut y avoir une colère qui monte
est-ce qu'il faut qu'il y ait une colère
qui monte est-ce que vous est-ce que
vous pensez que ça levier ou au
contraire on est dans un moment où on
peut peut-être avoir une union nationale
sur cette question là l'action sociale
j'attends des actes je pense que je suis
pas le seul
hier c'est bien joli de distribuer des
médailles de d'avoir des belles paroles
en direction de ces femmes et de ces
hommes disent qu'ils attendent c'est
d'être véritablement reconnu
on avait déposé un amendement qui est à
plusieurs reprises dans la dernière
période par exemple sur la limitation de
l'écart de salaire dans des entreprises
2 av
ces normes déjà un énorme bond cet
amendement a été repoussé
donc les inégalités savent si partie
intégrante du système dans lequel nous
sommes aujourd'hui qu'il faut
effectivement je crois fortement mettre
en cause donc on a on a on a
véritablement à mon avis de uno mais si
vous laissez la reconnaissance des
métiers la reconnaissance du travail
c'est les deux qu'il faut avoir
et donc ça passe effectivement par du
salaire mais pas que ça passe aussi par
dans les entreprises reconnaître la
qualification des gens d'accord alors on
va on va venir dans le détail des
propositions mais il ya quand même
quelque chose que disait stéphane tout à
l'heure c'est cette prime 1500 euros
pour les soignants ils ne l'ont toujours
pas touché
le décret a ni du temps est signée il va
l'être assure le gouvernement d'ailleurs
ça énerve beaucoup laurent berger
ecoutez-le il faut pas qu'on les oublie
il faut pas qu'on les oublie en termes
de reconnaissance demain et c'est pour
ça que je suis incroyablement agacé que
la la la le décret qui instaure les
primes le paiement des heures
supplémentaires soit pas encore sorti
tionnel hasard ce genre de retard c'est
déjà un mauvais signal oui on est dans
une période qui est particulière une
crise sanitaire qui est qui et qui est
massive et effectivement des engagements
étaient pris ils doivent être tenus et
dans les meilleurs délais parce que ces
personnes là ont des besoins de
reconnaissance est plus que de
reconnaissance est long
besoin que ces primes qui ont été
annoncés leur permettre aussi de boucler
les comment vous voulez vendre l'idée
c'est de la bureaucratie
la centralisation de l'état sa lourdeur
ça prend trop de temps il ya trop de
choses à faire en même temps je crois
qu'effectivement dans la période que
nous vivons il ya beaucoup de choses à
faire en même temps et que la
bureaucratie peut prendre un certain
temps et parfois beaucoup trop de temps
la question est maintenant de savoir
quand est-ce que ce sera fait je je
plais pour que ce soit le plus
rapidement possible qu'on corrige le tir
avec les engagements qui ont été pris
soient tenus dans les meilleurs délais
pour répondre aux engagements qui ont
été pris devant les français stéphane
mais je me demande est là parmi les
hypothèses évoquées pour expliquer le
retard gérer l'urgence
le fait qu'on ait fait beaucoup de tort
est-ce qu'on peut pas considérer que
l'amateurisme du gouvernement est une
hypothèse aussi qui expliquerait que un
mois n'a pas été suffisant pour buggy
pour rédiger un décret je ne pense pas
qu'on puisse parler d'amateurisme je
crois qu'on a fait face à une crise
sanitaire sans précédent une crise
sanitaire majeure une crise sanitaire
sans précédent que nous avons fait avec
la majorité pris un certain nombre de
dispositions massive pour éviter que
cette crise sanitaire se transforme en
crise économique est en crise sociale
beaucoup de dispositions ont été prises
je vous donne un exemple après demain ce
sont des millions de françaises et
français qui vont toucher une allocation
spécifique de solidarité pour les
ménages les plus modestes qui ont du mal
à boucler les fins de mois cette période
de crise donc on a pris beaucoup de
mesures des mesures très concrètes qui
ont été prises qui arrive qui vont être
sur le compte en banque de ces personnes
là et je maintenant ce qu'il faut qu'on
arrive à faire c'est que cette prime
pour les soignants puissent être versés
comme ça a été indiqué alors pierre
dharréville si on s'arrête au à
l'hôpital sur le public déjà qu est ce
que vous vous proposez parce que il ya
des propositions pour les soignants il
ya une proposition de loi d'ailleurs qui
commencent à émerger du côté de la
majorité
elle a été imaginé au départ par un
républicain maximino si je dis pas de
bêtises
un don un don d'une journée de congé aux
soignants sur la base du volontariat
pour financer l'hôpital et de personnels
hospitaliers gabon d'abord je vais faire
du mauvais esprit avec stéphane
blakowski 6
il me permet c'est vrai que le
gouvernement il a du mal qu'un my aller
au bout de la logique et à reconnaître y
compris qu'il est qu'il faut payer un
peu plus ces gens parce qu'il a refusé
de le faire pendant depuis depuis 2010
est il a refusé de le faire car pour les
salariés de l'hôpital et les soignants
et les non soignants ont ça c'est la
première chose la deuxième chose c'est
que il ya besoin d'une revalorisation on
a tout gelé pendant pendant des années
et donc c'est la première chose à faire
faut pas chercher comme ça à 12h à 14h
des petit subterfuge des logiques
d'entourloupe etc où on fait payer
d'ailleurs y compris en culpabilisant
les gens en leur disant c'est à vous de
payer donner vos congés pour les
soignants non non on creuse la dette on
est à 120% du pib il faut bien trouver
des ressources
cette idée d'un don vous avez des vues
et des dividendes ont été distribués à
l'appel en 2019 on atteint des sommets
des records bon ça ça pose jamais de
problème à personne en continu donc il
faut partager les richesses autrement
bon ça c'est une réalité
nous avons là il faut objectivement
effectivement une crise qui va affecter
notre économie là il ya un trou dans
lequel nous sommes en train de passer
donc il faut que on absorbe ce choc ça
c'est une évidence il faut l'absorber
dans la durée mais cela étant dit sur la
construction globale architecture de
notre économie
il faut changer des choses va continuer
comme ça c'est pas sérieux
donc on revoit la fiscalité je vais ils
travaillent des gens et donc pour payer
le travail des gens il faut financer
effectivement l'hôpital public art était
d'assécher la sueur de la sécurité
sociale et aux revenus c'est ce que vous
proposez notamment me rappelle le gendre
journaliste économique qui va intervenir
pas fait oui moi j'ai une une
interrogation effectivement d'abord il
serait peut-être bon de rappeler que 8
milliards d'euros vont être fléché vers
l'hôpital et vert franc santé publique
ça a été inscrit dans le dernier projet
de loi de finances rectificative donc
cet argent va venir mais moi je pose la
question c'est à dire qu'ils payent qui
paye pour cela est un sujet qu'on n'a
pas qu'on n'a pas encore évoqué c'est
celui de l'organisation de l'hôpital où
50 % de la masse salariale et ce sont
des fonctionnaires qui s'occupe de
l'administration en réalité donc
j'entends monsieur le député qui nous
dit il va falloir peut-être regarder du
côté du dividende donc peut-être
augmenter la fiscalité sur le capital
le capital c'est ce qui va manquer
drastiquement pour sauver nos
entreprises leur sont propres
donc est ce que c'est vraiment le moment
alors que on va se prendre en pleine
face une récession qu'on n'a pas connue
depuis 1944 d'augmenter d'augmenter
encore les impôts alors que la france et
on l'a dit un mille fois le pays déjà le
plus taxés au monde
on a vous l'avez dit une dette qui va
monter à 115 ou 120 % du pib
qui va payer allez loin de la question
centrale
elle est très bien posé à sa façon par
par un autre intervenant c'est qui
décide c'est l'argent qui décide c'est
ce que l'argent qui décide où c'est la
démocratie c'est nous qui décidons
comment on emploie les richesses qu'on
produit c'est ça le sujet aujourd'hui et
de manière massive
c'est effectivement ce qui rend les
capitaux qui décide où est ce qu'il est
investi et c'est un problème donc une
conférence sociale par exemple avec
l'ensemble des syndicats comme le
réclame
laurent berger ou patrick mignola qui
est modem dans la majorité ça peut être
une manière de bien décider moi j'ai
beaucoup apprécié quand ils ont sorti ce
texte parce que ça fait des mois voire
des années même avant que cette majorité
n'arrive au pouvoir que nous demandons
une grande conférence sur les salaires
et ça nous semble être effectivement une
discussion qu'il faut mener
donc oui allons-y discutons de ce sujet
metal sur la table china laser faut tout
mettre sur la table on va pas refaire le
débat sur l' isf parce qu'on sait que
voilà on n'a à ma gauche quelqu'un qui
veut le remettre sur la table
revoir la fiscalité des revenus je ne
pense pas que vous irez sur cette route
mais ici ce qui est ce qu'il ya des
sujets tabous ou pas je crois je crois
que cette crise ne doit nous amener à
remettre beaucoup de cartes sur la table
et qu'effectivement ce sont des
questions que nous devons nous poser y
compris la fiscalité des hauts revenus
pris la fiscalité des hauts revenus
même si on sait qu effectivement
aujourd'hui il ya quand même trois
salariés sur quatre qui sont payés par
l'état dans la crise que nous sommes en
train de vivre
donc il faut quand même que l'essai du
souffle aux entreprises aux entreprises
que les entreprises puissent se relever
quand même revenus doivent pouvoir
contribuer à leur mesure où fait pour
vous redire à une entreprise il va
falloir augmenter les salaires alors que
traverse une crise économique très
importante on peut le faire il ya des
incitations fiscales pour ça pourquoi ne
pas augmenter le smic c'est ce que
propose pierre dharréville est-ce que
c'est raisonnable dans la période c'est
possible vous savez le début du
quinquennat on a pris beaucoup de
mesures d'encouragement pour que les
entreprises augmentent les salaires je
pense notamment à la question de
l'intéressement et de la participation y
compris dans les plus petites
entreprises avec la loi pacte et puis
l'état a aussi participé donc mieux
rémunérer le travail
oui par l'escale maîtrise et et quel
jour l'état général à la prime
d'activité pour permettre aux plus bas
revenus de gagner en pouvoir d'achat
donc moi c'est une décomposition
générale l'intérêt intéressement aller
l'applaudir cipation aller plus loin et
puis bien sûr il faut que les
organisations professionnelles se parle
avec les syndicats et que oui des
augmentations soient décidées par les
entreprises avec des incitations
fiscales pourquoi pas de la part de
l'état stephane sur le smic vous vouliez
intervenir
ah oui mais j'entendais qui avait des
projets de grandes réunions à grenelle
comme on dit à un grenelle du pouvoir
d'achat alors mais je rappelle que
grenelle c'est quand même une réunion
qui est lue après mai 68 sous la
pression de la rue sous la pression des
salariés et qu'il ya eu une augmentation
de 35 % du smic
à l'époque mais ça ne s'est pas fait
sans la pression c'est pas le
gouvernement de l'époque qui s'énerve
qu'udine c'est insupportable que les par
ailleurs utile gagnant alors oui je
crois après se soit passé comme ça qu'il
faut des contre-pouvoirs il faut une
pression citoyenne pour obtenir à la fin
que les les indispensables soient soient
justement et mieux rémunéré c'est ça je
vais je crois de toute façon qu'il ya
dans ce pays comme dans tout dans le
monde entier effectivement un
affrontement un conflit d'intérêts qui
existe et donc il faut faire il faut que
c'est il faut que les gens puissent se
faire entendre mais j'y vais demain
s'ils croient qu'ils n'ont pas été
beaucoup entendu quand même depuis deux
ans et demi mais là on est à un moment
charnière
justement est-ce pas mouche à passer
autrement dans l'aveyron l'inventaire on
a lancé une plate-forme qui s'appelle le
jour d'après qui a permis de donner la
parole à la société civile aux citoyens
aux associations aux syndicats on a eu
26 mille personnes qui ont participé
soixante six parlementaires 22 ateliers
qui sont tenus et plusieurs centaines de
propositions est l'une des propositions
phares qui est ressorti de cette
consultation
c'est la revalorisation des salaires des
soignants alors le montant qui est
évoqué ces 200 euros pourquoi 200 euros
je ne sais pas vous dire si c'est le
chiffre qui est le bon mais en tout cas
c'est ce qui est ressorti de cette
consultation mais sur un point de
méthodes il faut embarquer il faut
embarquer large
vous craignez des convulsions sociales
est-ce qu'il va y avoir de la casse
moi je suis si vous ne faites pas ses
gestes vite il risque d'y avoir beaucoup
de colère je crois qu'on a on a vécu une
période difficile avec la période des
gilet jaune
on sort d'une période difficile avec la
crise du coc vide
je crois qu'il serait dangereux pour le
pays de retomber dans une période de
crise avec des violences réelles
donc je pense qu'il faut prendre les
mesures c'est aussi pour ça que toutes
les mesures d'urgence ont été prises
pour les plus fragiles pour sauver les
entreprises pour sauver les emplois et
il faut continuer je pense que la
révalorisation des bas salaire doit
faire partie de l'agenda ont valorisé
les bas salaires est ce que vous allez
le faire affaire à suivre ou à faire le
point avec raphaël pour terminer sur la
casse sociale justement qu'est ce qui
peut se passer en termes de destructions
d'emplois jusqu'où l'économie peut
s'effondrer
bah oui myriam effectivement on parle
déjà de hausses de salaires mais la
priorité pour les semaines et les mois
qui vont arriver ça va être la
préservation de l'emploi je vous donne
un chiffre 450 3800 c'est le nombre
d'emplois qui ont été détruits au
premier trimestre après seulement deux
semaines de confinement pour vous donner
un ordre de grandeur
c'est grosso modo le nombre d'emplois
qui avaient été créés depuis l'élection
d' emmanuel macron il y a trois ans et
malheureusement ce n'est pas fini le fc
le par exemple l'organisme de prévision
de sciences po paris estime qu'à la fin
du déconfinement
on pourrait arriver à 620 milles emplois
détruits ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'on a déjà probablement dépassé la
barre des 10% de chômage en france est
ce qu'on sait qu'ils qui a été touché
oui alors malheureusement les plus
précaires un quart des contrats
d'intérim et de contrats courts ont été
détruits au 31 mars
c'est près de 300000 personnes qui ont
ainsi perdu leur emploi
et ça c'est que la première vague ils
ont perdu parce que les entreprises
n'avaient pas de visibilité sur l'avenir
ce sont aussi les premiers qui vont
retrouver des emplois quand l'activité
même partiellement repartira mais il ya
une deuxième vague qui va il est cette
deuxième vague c'est celle des 12,4
millions d'actifs qui sont aujourd'hui
au chômage partiel et dont on sait
qu'une partie ne retrouvera pas son
emploi quand l'état retire à ce
dispositif d'assistance respiratoire du
chômage partiel
les estimations varient sur la part de
ces gens qui ne retrouveront pas mais il
faudrait ajouter à cela aussi tous les
jeunes diplômés qui vont arriver cette
année sur le marché de l'emploi sept
cent mille jeunes qui vont arriver à la
rentrée sur un marché aux portes closes
tout ça dans l'ensemble ça donne entre
eux alors les variations sont très
larges mais entre 600 mille et trois
millions de chômeurs supplémentaires
d'ici un an qui pourraient compter la
france alors l'état bien sûr réagi face
à cela des mesures sont en place des
mesures pour les jeunes devraient être
présentées à la rentrée dans le plan de
relance par un prono le maire et chez
muriel pénicaud on réfléchit à
réorienter les salariés des secteurs qui
sont le plus touchés par la crise on
pense au tourisme à l'hôtellerie et à la
restauration pour les réorienter vers
les secteurs qui sont en demande comme
le bâtiment une partie du commerce des
aides à la personne et transports ou la
logistique
bon ce sujet est absolument majeur
pourquoi parce que le travail c'est le
principal déterminant de la confiance
des français
et sans confiance les français ne
consommeront pas dans les mois et les
années à venir c'est pourtant le
principal levier de la croissance et
on sait ce qu avait souligné edouard
philippe en parlant d' écroulement de
l'économie
voilà et donc on a un président de la
république qui est face à un problème
majeur qui est l'inversion de la courbe
du chômage peut-être que ça vous
rappelle quelqu'un d'autre absolument
merci raphaël d'ailleurs c'est le destin
de chacun dans votre journal dans
l'opinion
aujourd'hui voilà il explique les choses
en un dessin bien mieux que je ne
saurais le faire merci beaucoup
vous avez du boulot comment on répond à
une crise sociale en même temps qu'à une
crise économique
bon courage et peut-être qui sait
l'union nationale sera peut être au
rendez vous un peu plus tard elle ne
l'est pas aujourd'hui merci à vous cette
question à présent
faut-il revoter en juin prochain pour
les municipales on se souvient de
l'avalanche de critiques et même des
quatre contamination après le premier
tour c'était une semaine avant le
confinement de tout le pays c'était le
15 mars dernier
aujourd'hui l'idée de faire revoter les
français et vittel fait son chemin
est ce que c'est bien raisonnable avant
d'accueillir de nouveaux invités voyez
le sujet dame est à dire
souvenez vous c'était il y a deux mois
un premier tour des élections
municipales maintenu en pleine crise
sanitaire et des citoyens présents kg et
je sais pas si j'irai dans les quinze
jours
ça va évoluer parce qu'effectivement et
on ya dix morts supplémentaires chaque
jour j'irai voter je suis même assez
c'est donc vers un atelier y avait six
afin qu'ils prennent
résultat les vainqueurs des dernières
élections et les maires sortants ne se
sont toujours pas passé le relais et
l'exécutif est sortie affaiblie dans cet
épisode
je crois que depuis le début et
notamment à travers la question des
élections municipales qui ont été
maintenues au même moment où on
annonçait la fermeture des cafés des
restaurants des commerces au même moment
où on demandait aux personnes les plus
âgées de rester chez elle a tout de
suite installé une forme
d'incompréhension dans l'opinion le
sentiment d'injonction contradictoires
et très souvent dans les crises de ce
type quand on parle du mauvais pied en
termes de d'opinion publique c'est très
difficile d'inverser la tendance par la
suite l'imbroglio va prendre fin d'ici
le 28 mai à cette date les conseils
municipaux élus dès le premier tour
auront désigner leurs maires c'est le
premier ministre qui l'a su puisque dès
lors que nous avons commencé le
déconfinement il paraît possible dans
trente mille des communes sur les 35
mille que compte notre pays
d'installer les conseils municipaux
lesquels sont le plus souvent composé de
15 membres au maximum restent 5000
autres communes les plus grandes
principalement qui attendent un second
tour le ps comme la droite favori dans
de nombreuses villes veulent organiser
d'ici l'été
il met en avant l'argument économique
évidemment le plus tôt sera le mieux si
les conditions sanitaires permettent
pourquoi parce que la relance du pays
passera aussi par une relance de la
commande publique et que les communes
représentent 70 à 80 % des commandes
publiques et donc si on veut relancer
après il faut relancer le btp est donc
installé les conseils municipaux d'une
part ce qui sera prévu dans la semaine
du 23 au 28 mai mais également donner
des nouvelles équipes municipales et
terminer ces élections un second tour en
juin salle des quatre colonnes à
l'assemblée nationale tous ne partagent
pas cet avis il y a ceux pour qui il ne
faut pas faire la même erreur qu'en mars
dernier
question simple est-ce qu'il faut
organiser un second tour d'élections
municipales en juin ou en septembre
questions réponses simples à ce que le
gouvernement a un masque par électeur à
mettre à leur disposition à l'entrée du
bureau de vote avec du gel
hydroalcoolique des protections pour les
assesseurs pour les présidents de bureau
- jawad ouaddouch normes et donc report
tout dépend des moyens qui sont mis à
disposition par le gouvernement qui peut
répondre moi je pense qu'à partir nous
les cafés ne sont pas réouvert sarr
qu'on peut pas tenir des réunions des
cafés peut-être que ça se produit lors
d'une campagne électorale partie on
comprend à qui fit si de faire du porte
à porte pour aller voir les gens qui est
assez classique lors d'une élection
c'est délicat d'imaginer que
on puisse tenir en second tour dans ce
contexte là il y aura pas deux campagnes
électorales dans l'entourage des manuels
macro comme d'edouard philippe on
affirme qu'ils sont favorables à ce que
le second tour se tienne le plus vite
possible
le gouvernement attend l'avis du conseil
scientifique pour se prononcer il est
attendu au plus tard le 23 mai bonsoir
agent est merci d'être là vous êtes
député la république en marge des
français de l'étranger ceux qui habitent
en asie principalement à vous est
également médecin consultant en risques
sanitaires est liée au risque pandémique
s'étale élus mais aussi à la médecin que
j'aime a dressé ce soir bienvenue
emmanuel rivière
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes
spécialiste de l'opinion directeur
général france de kantar public et
bonsoir philippe laurent maire
merci d'être là vous êtes le maire udi
de la ville de sceaux dans les
hauts-de-seine vous avez largement vous
êtes arrivé en tête du premier tour aux
dernières municipales donc dans votre
commune vous êtes secrétaire général de
l'association des maires de france la mf
qui avec d'autres associations de maires
étaient entendus par les députés cet
après midi je vais commencer par vous
philippe laurent sans nous réellement
prêt pourquoi vous militez pour la tenue
au plus vite de ce second tour dès le
mois de juin
alors dire qu'on humilie ton n'est pas
exact ce que nous disons c'est la chose
suivante
d'abord il faut que les communes et les
intercommunalités qui sont de très gros
investisseurs qui y joueront un rôle
important dans la relance économique
puisse être à pied d'oeuvre et puis donc
quand des décisions et que rapidement
possible avec des équipes qui aura été
totalement légitime et vous a pas
échappé que il ya eu trente mille 30
mille communes qui ont élus finalement
leur île de la cdu au premier tour vont
être installés d'ailleurs c'est très
prochainement puisque premier ministre
un bon il ya un texte qui est en cours
et qui permettra d'installer ses
conseils municipaux des communes très
prochainement mais les amis l'autre
commune pour lequel le deuxième tour
naples est le premier temps n'a pas été
conclue cif
ce sont en fait généralement des villes
moyennes et grandes
et ce sont elles qui investissent le
plus pourquoi par conséquent il est
quand même important pour la reprise
économique pour la relance que ses
équipes soient à pied d'oeuvre
lui aussi expliqué qu on m'expliquait
tout d'abord monsieur le maire
expliquez-nous pouvoir d'inviter
malaisie allez-y tamina je veux dire est
que la responsabilité de l'organisation
de ce second tour
au mois de juin elle appartient
pleinement et au gouvernement et d'être
vraiment parlement nous nous si les
conditions sanitaires
si le parlement et le gouvernement
estime que les conditions de sanitaires
ne sont pas réunies eh bien nous
militerons pas spécialement pour
l'organisation du second tour en voiture
je crois qu'il faut que ce soit clair
très bien je voulais revenir sur la
question économique
un maire qui est en place un maire
sortant qui reste maire de sa commune
il ne se sent pas légitime d'investir ou
de donner des permis de construire pour
l'avenir où il n'a pas le droit de le
faire pour bien comprendre cette
question de la commande publique
oui dans bien sûr le maire le maire
actuel le maire est en place à l'heure
actuelle il est pleinement légitime peut
le faire il faut aussi que il est
l'accord de son conseil municipal sera
sa bande sujets sains pour de quoi le
maire mais ils nous suivent mais
actuellement il ne peut pas forcément
s'autoriser du fait qu' il est un peu en
stand by c'est ça ce que vous voulez
dire oui parce qu'ils ne seraient pas
moralement acceptable qu'un maire qui
est donc qui en balance ou qui n'a pas
cette certitude d'être mère puisque
encore une fois c'est vrai pour 30 pile
mais offrent les cinq villes hôtes ils
diraient ils ne seraient pas moralement
acceptable ce maire engage par trop des
finances de sa collectivité sur des
sondés avaient donc il ya des projets
qui sont forcément sinon annulé mais en
tout cas suspendue alors merci philippe
laurent vous êtes sensible à ces
arguments la gamme argument économique
en pleine crise est ce qu'on peut se
permettre au fonds de reporter signer
dès ce second tour
alors j'entends l'argument économique et
je l'entends tout à fait d'autant plus
que je suis moi même élu municipal
maintenant depuis le premier tour je
fais partie des
trente mille communes dont le conseil
municipal a pu être élu dès le 15 mars
et dont j'ai hâte d'avoir notre exécutif
désigner entre le 23 et le 28 mai
prochain
mais en même temps nous avons un enjeu
sanitaire derrière qui ne peut pas être
ignorée on reste dans l'ambition je
crois que l'ensemble des français la
partage de les protéger on n'a pas du
tout envie de compter les dcd c'est pas
l'objectif
on veut que l'ensemble de l'économie
repart bien entendu dans les meilleures
conditions sanitaires qui soit et puis
un second tour des municipales c'est pas
juste une date c'est toute une campagne
qui précède donc l'analyse de la
situation sanitaire doit se faire à la
lumière de toute cette durée de campagne
c'est quoi une campagne on ne peut pas
imaginer une campagne si on ne peut pas
aux campagnes dans les cadets c'est à
des fins que du skype que des skype
héros et il ya un moment ça devient un
peu compliqué il faut comme se
rencontrer se parler
donc il faut prendre ça en compte et le
médecin que vous êtes a priori on attend
à l'heure l'avis du conseil scientifique
du comité scientifique j'ai dit
attention à leur auto je n'ai pas de
doute sur le fait que conseil
scientifique sera parfaitement éclairé
aura ces données épidémiologiques et ses
modélisations qui permettra de voir que
regardons-nous mais malgré sa décision
d'avoir dit oui au premier tour ces
critiques et là on est dans une
situation différente on est dans une
suite de phase iii s'est pas tout à fait
la même chose que ce qu'on était au tout
départ on n'est pas du tout dans les
mêmes conditions
on sait maintenant à quel air 0 nous
sommes circonvient de personnes peut
contaminer un malade donc nettement en
dessous de 1 et nous voudrions descendre
encore plus en dessous de 1
le plus possible au début juin pour
pouvoir se dire allez en ré ouvre un
petit peu en ayant de campagne
électorale peut être que ce nombre de
personnes contaminées sera un peu plus
élevé mais on reste dans des conditions
raisonnables de dacca de d'encaissement
je dirais du système de santé et de
risques pour nos concitoyens ça
resterait raisonnable mais les rivières
ils peuvent comprendre les français ce
genre de débat et si on revotait le mois
prochain où c'est au fond quasiment
inaudible là pour l'instant enfin le les
municipales c'est le dernier grand tact
effets politiques auxquels on a
participé avant de basculer dans tout
autre chose et ce moment incroyable
de manière obsessionnelle finalement
toutes nos préoccupations de nos
conversations ont été accaparées par par
la pandémie donc revoter voudrait dire
que ça y est tout ça est un peu un peu
derrière nous je crois je crois
qu'aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas et c'est
vrai qu'à côté du problème de la fois
économiques et politiques publiques et
par philippe laurent à côté du problème
sanitaire que pose le fait de remettre
beaucoup de gens en interaction il ya le
problème démocratique et qui en plus
permet pas de trancher parce que d'un
côté qu'est ce que c'est que cette
espèce d'entre-deux tours interminable
avec quelque chose qui va être
totalement inédit et c'est pas comme si
les pas de suspense dans un certain
nombre de très grandes villes un que
soit lyon marseille montpellier à
bordeaux l'affairé tout sauf jouer donc
se demander comment on veut tenir
longtemps comme ça et à l'elysée à
anvers qui est est ce que les français
sont prêts à voter
voilà parce que la première fois il y
avait quand même moins d'un français sur
deux qui cdac c'est là toute la question
d'y avoir une abstention massive
il ya ce risque d'autant plus que je
m'attarderai pas faire un pronostic là
dessus mais les gens ils sont allés
beaucoup moins que d'habitude 20 points
de participation en moins alors que la
veille on prenait les transports on
allait faire ses courses et que l'on a
le restaurant et on était face à un
risque un peu impalpable et là sur
beaucoup de dimensions on voit bien
qu'on cherche plutôt le risque zéro or
on peut pas promettre le risque zéro
charles 25 humanitaire mais du point de
vue de la perception et donc ça va être
très très compliqué je mens pas être à
la place de celui qui devra trancher
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que j'ai
l'impression qu'on cherche beaucoup à
mutualiser la décision et on aimerait un
peu le parent prix je crois aussi qu'il
faut bien comprendre que juin juillet
août septembre octobre novembre
vivien russie sera toujours là il sera
toujours là plus ou moins agressif plus
ou moins en grande quantité mais il sera
toujours là donc il ya bien un moment où
il faut que la vie reprenne y compris la
vie démocratique
vous avez vu que le monde dans un
article aujourd'hui nous explique que le
gouvernement envisage de faire voter le
parlement sur la date du second tour des
élections municipales
après la décision évidemment du
gouvernement et après la décision du
comité scientifique ça pourrait être une
porte de sortie démocratique à une
décision
de démocratie alors de toute façon dont
notre système démocratique
associer le parlement à cette décision
moi je ne peux que m'en réjouir je pense
que c'est une excellente chose nous
sommes les élus du peuple nous avons
notre mot à dire sur ses choix
essentiels qui conduisent voté en juin
madame le d'éviter de voter quoi pour
voter en juin si vous deviez voter oui
ou non vous dites quoi
alors j'ai besoin d'avoir le rapport du
conseil scientifique là qui va tomber
c'est la semaine prochaine je crois et
qui va fonder le rapport du gouvernement
après et est la lumière enfin c'est plus
d'ailleurs l'avis du conseil
scientifique dans un premier temps tant
que médecin que je vais regarder de près
et ses conseillers scientifiques en
fonction ce qui dit ben je verrais vers
quoi je m'oriente vous fait confiance
comme ça il y actuellement où il ya
aucun doute je lui fais tout à fait
confiance qui livrent laurent qu'est ce
que vous pensez de ces échanges
à entendre madame la députée ça n'est
pas tout à fait fait ce vote de deuxième
tour d'ici le mois de juin
non non mais je roulais dit nous nous
avons simplement avancé des arguments de
la question de la reprise économique et
la vie démocratique
et encore une fois nous considérons je
suis clair là dessus
considérant que la responsabilité en
revient au gouvernement et au parlement
donc nous nous nous militerons me pour
une accélération du calendrier ni pour
un ralentissement je dis ça mais on met
simplement cet élément donc en dans le
débat si je pense qu'en effet cet
élément n'est pas forcément le plus
important que c'est évidemment la
situation sanitaire qui compte ce
d'autant plus que comme l'a dit madame
la députée une campagne électorale même
de second tour il ya quand même eu de
campagne
il faut donc sur la campagne ça veut
dire que donc ça commence avant
admettons que ce soit le 28 juin un bon
ça commence bien avant ça commence quand
même quinze jours avant il ya la
question du dépôt des listes qui est pas
qui est pas réglé il ya la question de
la fusion éventuellement de liste qui
n'est pas réglée qui a qui est un enjeu
important surtout dans les grandes
villes comme on disait tout à l'heure
c'est pas réglé en plein de situations
qui ne sont en règle et on ne peut pas
savoir ce second tour et donc par
conséquent il y a
donc encore nous et pourtant je suis le
chemin on se tait ce second tour sans
confession merci philippe laurent
d'avoir été derrière votre écran en
direct avec nous depuis votre ville de
sceaux d'un mot vraiment très rapidement
emmanuel rivière les français s'en fiche
un peu de cette question non alors ils
n'ont pas en tête mais le jour où elle
viendra ce qui est très important c'est
qu'ils n'aient pas le sentiment qu'on
leur dise d'aller voter par une sorte de
calcul électoral où parquer des
questions d'opportunité mais parce que
c'est vraiment le moment et c'est vrai
que leur jeu collectif s'est trouvé un
consensus là dessus
merci beaucoup merci à john thème merci
emmanuel rivière d'être venu sur le
plateau parlements du monde parce qu'il
n'ya pas qu'au parlement français que
les débats sont houleux
notre chroniqueur franco britannique
préféré alex taylor fait lui aussi son
retour dans cette émission alex mercredi
ce sont les traditionnelles questions au
premier ministre au parlement de
westminster et il s'est passé quelque
chose d'incroyable racontez nous oui
bonsoir mejia mans en effet les mesures
sanitaires liés aux kobe 19 prive la
chambre des communes de ses
traditionnels alors on aura parce que
vaille que ils n'ont pas le droit
d'applaudir dans le parlement que c est
beaucoup moins de députés
donc les débats et surtout les questions
au premier ministre sont du coup
beaucoup plus calme et plus pointus
surtout depuis l'arrivée il a un mois du
nouveau leader de l'opposition qui est à
ma soeur qui est amorphe ancien avocat
et ça se voit il est chirurgicale dans
la manière dont il questionne le premier
ministre en l'occurrence aujourd'hui sur
les conseils pour les managers des ehpad
en gros mental
8000 décès en moyenne en temps normal
pour moi d'avril 26000 pour le mois
d'avril dernier
pourquoi demandons instamment le
gouvernement a ainsi publié un rapport
officiel le 12 mars dernier affirmant
qu'il était très peu probable que les
résidents des ehpad soit contaminée
regardez
changes le 12 mars les conseils publié
par le gouvernement affirmait je les
cite qu'il était très peu probable que
les résidents en ehpad soit infecté le
premier ministre est il d'accord pour
dire que le gouvernement a agi trop
lentement pour protéger ses résidents
non monsieur le speaker ce n'est pas
vrai ce n'était pas des conseils publié
par le gouvernement et nous avons
confiné les ehpad avant le confinement
général alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé
ensuite alex pas comme je le disais tout
à l'heure
johnson fait face non seulement un
simple avocat mais surtout à l'ancien
directeur des poursuites pénales en
grand beau temps
ces curieuses qui ne laisse rien filtrer
à peine une heure après les changes vous
dites voir qui est amer a écrit au
premier ministre une lettre officielle
exigeant que jason reviennent au
parlement s'excuser d'avoir menti devant
lui débuter mon tir à la chambre des
communes c'est quelque chose qui ne se
fait pas du tout voici la lettre je cite
par temps de crise il est plus important
que jamais que l'on puisse compter sur
l'exactitude des informations données
par le gouvernement
mais plus largement si vous voulez c'est
tout le style johnson qui est mise en
cause
il a gagné le
le break site avec son latéral anglais
du blaster c'est un peu l'art et la
manière de dire tout et n'importe quoi
mais avec beaucoup d enthousiasme mais
face à sa gestion un peu chaotique il
faut dire la crise qu vide et surtout
face à quelqu'un comme kia starmer
eh bien j'ai envie de dire qu'il a peut
être rencontré son batteur nous mais
c'est pas exactement ça mais vous voyez
ce que je veux dire absolument alex on
ne pardonne plus le mensonge en
politique 24 heures à l'assemblée
à présent c'est l'heure du carnet de
route de thomas des prêts thomas et les
hutus mans ce soir
oui regardez myriam c'est ici dans
l'hémicycle que les députés sont en
train d'examiner la proposition de loi
qui lutte contre les contenus haineux en
ligne c'est le premier texte à
l'assemblée depuis la crise du
coronavirus je vous raconte tout ça dans
ma journée à l'assemblée alors c'est une
lecture définitive ce texte il est déjà
venu à l'assemblée et au sénat il est
porté par laetitia via qui est député la
république en marche de paris et il vise
à mettre fin à l'impunité de la haine
sur internet et a obligé les plateformes
à supprimer les contenus haineux un
texte plus que d'actualité pour laetitia
vient quand on laisse les plateformes
fixer les règles du jeu fixées le
curseur choisir quels sujets priorisés
dans la modération
ce sont les victimes qui paye alors
aujourd'hui nous reprenons les rênes
concrètement le texte oblige les
plateformes à supprimer toute incitation
à la haine et à la discrimination
qu'elle soit à caractère raciste
religieux ou liées à l'orientation
sexuelle et ce 24 heures après le
signalement sous peine d'une grosse
amende et pour les contenus à caractère
pédopornographique ou terroristes ce
délai est réduit à une heure après leur
signalement alors sans contester la
nécessité de lutter contre la haine sur
les réseaux sociaux
l'opposition craint des effets pervers
c'est une loi en vérité qui va pratiquer
un arbitraire ou du moins qui va donner
la possibilité à des grands opérateurs
d'organiser une censure quasi immédiate
et donc nous aurons là quelque chose qui
va évidemment réduire la liberté
d'expression alors forcément la majorité
lui a répondu
ce qui n'est pas autorisé dans la vraie
vie ne doit plus l'être non plus dans la
vie numérique et cela doit être encadrée
c'est ce que permet cette fois avec des
outils adaptés
voilà pour la discussion thomas sauf que
à peine discuter cette proposition de
loi de laëtitia rabia elle a été
percutée par une polémique
la députée marcheuses elle est mise en
cause par le site d'information
mediapart
elle est accusée d'avoir tenu des propos
racistes oui exactement ça tombe très
mal une enquête poutrelles éthiciens via
la députée lrm qui horrifie ses
assistants cette page dans lesquels un
journaliste on recense des messages dans
lesquels la députée aurait tenu des
propos racistes homophobes ou sexistes à
l'encontre de ses collaborateurs capture
d'écran à l'appui ce matin laetitia via
a réagi sur twitter pour elle le
journaliste en question déjà auteur de
plusieurs articles sur elle mène une
campagne d'acharnement aujourd'hui ip
atteint on serre pas la main
est ce que vous vous acharnez sur les
qui si elle vient elle parle
d'acharnement moi je parle d'une
information d'intérêt public gip
seulement des bribes de documents qu'on
révèle ses des témoignages
circonstanciés recoupées avec laeticia
répondu qu'elle allait porter plainte ce
qu'elle conteste plus particulièrement
c'est le détournement de messages privés
sortis de leur contexte pour leur faire
dire pour faire dire autre chose qu on a
le sentiment qu'on à faire ramasser tout
ce qu'on pouvait pour tenter de
construire un article mais qui au final
est quand même gravement accusatoire
qu'on publie la veille du jour où elle
porte un projet de loi qui lui inquiète
beaucoup de gens et donc lutte contre la
haine sur internet et on est quasiment
la première victime est dans l'hémicycle
tout à l'heure le secrétaire d'état au
numérique cedrico a apporté son soutien
à letizia à vire ça fait un an que je
travaille quasiment quotidiennement et
qui tient bien et que laissait penser
qu'elle puisse être raciste ou homophobe
est un non sens absolu pour ce qui est
du texte sur les contenus haineux en
ligne myriam il a été définitivement
adopté en fin d'après midi
merci thomas pour ce carnet de route ma
journée à l'assemblée on termine comme
promis avec notre grand entretien
quotidien sur le monde d'après
l'épidémie aujourd'hui
le numérique une économie qui va
connaître une croissance exponentielle
elle était déjà rebond santé l'économie
numérique mais attention attention à la
numérisation du monde jour d'après avec
l'économiste daniel cohen c'est une
collection signée françois chevret
charlotte et panne est pas là avec qui
prit est gris on n'est pas dans votre
bureau ou la non on est dans la salle à
manger parce que mon bureau je reçois
moins bien le ça saute
[Musique]
bonjour daniel cohen bonjour en quoi le
numérique sera pour vous un élément clé
de la sortie de crise alors je sais pas
si c'est un élément de sortie de crise
je pense que c'est surtout un
accélérateur des tendances actuelles
c'est-à-dire que quand on regarde ce que
cette crise font tout simplement
elle empêche le face à face et
l'empêchent qu'on se voit et on est
obligé au fond de mobiliser toutes
sortes de technologies qui d'une
certaine manière attendant ce moment ce
moment où la distanciation sociale
deviendra une règle et où la
communication avec autrui passerait
systématiquement par l'intermédiaire de
ses tablettes de ces sites diverses et
variées et en réalité je crois qu'on vit
un moment tout à fait étonnant d'une
crise sanitaire qui est en train
d'accélérer les grandes tendances de la
transformation du monde depuis un an
plusieurs plusieurs années peuvent être
décennies c'est vrai que l'économie du
numérique explose dans la période les
ventes de tablettes d'ordinateurs jeff
bezos le patron d'amazon s'est augmenté
sa fortune a augmenté de 22 milliards
d'euros netflix n'en parlons même pas
l'économie numérique s'est bien portée
jusqu'à présent qu'est ce qu'elle est en
train de vivre un véritable âge d'or en
ce moment des pauses ou en tout cas
peut-être même le début d'un âge d'or et
il faut comprendre pourquoi elle et s'y
adapter et cette situation alors que
s'appelle manière
permettait de le penser l'économie du
numérique
c'est ce qui permet d'industrialiser la
société de services dans lequel on est
entré on a quitté la société
industrielle depuis longtemps maintenant
on a longtemps parlé de sociétés post
industrielles pour caractériser le monde
dans lequel on était ce qui
naturellement ne voulait rien dire du
tout postindustrielle sa voulais juste
dire qu'on avait quitté le monde
industriel a fallu du temps pour qu'on
comprenne de quoi il s'agit c'est
vraiment laid dans un de mes dix qui
s'appelait il faut dire que les temps
changent et je revenais à la prédiction
d'un grand économiste français qui
s'appelait jean saura ce qu'il il faut
rester disait la chose suivante
l'humanité pendant des millénaires à
travailler la terre
puis pendant des siècles elle a
travaillé la matière ces passages d'une
société agraire à une société
industrielle
nous entrons dans une période au cours
de laquelle l'homme a travaillé loeb
loeb lui-même
l'ailier que le propre de cette société
post industrielle
c'était une société dans lequel on
s'occupe les uns des autres comme
éducateur comme aide-soignant comme
coach sportif comme si canellis voilà
l'idée qu'elle est jean fourastié du
monde à venir
il ajoutait deux choses la première
c'est que c'était un grand espoir
ces types de son livre grand espoir du
20e siècle enfin l'économie allait être
humanisée et il a ajouté un codicille de
plus ce qu'ils étaient petit problème
mais qui pour lui dans n'était pas un
cette société de services
elle ne va pas créer de croissance
économique pourquoi parce que la valeur
du bien
c'est le temps que je passe avec autrui
je suis aide soignant le temps que je
passe avec la personne malade
c'est ça le bien en réalité que je
produis donc comme le temps des bases
extensible il n'y aura plus de
croissance économique est bien que fait
le numérique il est en train d'apporter
autre nîmes est une solution à ce
problème de fouras kg et il est en train
d'industrialiser cette économie de face
à face
comment est bien en nous faisant passer
par les tablettes et autres qu'on est en
train d'utiliser ses délires en
numérisant les relations de face à face
en faisant vous soyez une information
que je peux traiter en faisant que en
cliquant sur quelque chose j'ai accès à
plusieurs qui
à la fois peut-être je vais entrer dans
une phase où la croissance va redevenir
possible mais une croissance qui n'est
pas du tout celle qui avait prédite pour
acier une croissance en réalité
déshumanisant mettons à distance le
prestataire et le client bref le type de
croissance que ce moment de confinement
en propice et ce nouveau capitalisme
numérique dont vous parlez il irait
jusqu où on peut numériser jusqu'où on
peut numériser le monde est bien lui
pensent les gaffes à les gens qui
travaillent à la silicon valley les
spécialistes de l'intelligence
artificielle pense que tout peut être
numérisés l'intelligence humaine peut
être numérisés vos émotions peuvent être
numérisés ce que vous êtes votre état de
santé peut être numérisés c'est
peut-être une des choses les plus
claires de cette période c'est que la
médication à distance va progresser
voire des tablettes qui vont être
capables de faire un diagnostic avec un
médecin à notre goût très loin je ne dis
pas que le travail demain va
nécessairement disparaître mais la
relation de face à face va être réduite
à la portion congrue ya un film qui est
formidable pour comprendre ce qui se
passe c'est le film 1 h vers le film
dans lequel le héros incarné par joaquim
phoenix tombe amoureux d'un logiciel et
on comprend pourquoi parce que ce
logiciel et mettez merveilleux il a la
voix de scarlett johannson il connaît
tous deux dû du héros il connaît ses
fantasmes ses phobies elle est capable
de lui chanter des chansons de lui lui
des récits de promener de temps en temps
il ya quand même besoin d'une relation
physique l'amour ça passe aussi par le
corps alors en effet pendant deux heures
une femme bien faire l'amour avec
joaquin phoenix c'est la voix de
scarlett johansson qui parle encore et
donc on voit que la relation de face à
face c'est vraiment le cas de le dire
est réduite à sa portion congrue et
l'imaginaire de ceux qui réfléchissent
eux monde de demain il est entièrement
habité par cette idée que les réseaux
sociaux valent mieux que les relations
de face à face que le télétravail puisse
devenir la règle alors on voit que c'est
un fantasme évidemment et
que c'était une dystopie on ne veut pas
d'un monde
ce qu on ne se rencontre plus les uns
les autres mais vous savez le xxème
siècle c'est l'air d'une société
industrielle ou le travail à la chaîne
avait produit une incroyable d
humanisation du travail et n la
contrepartie avec des périodes de
prospérité
on comprend aujourd'hui que la
prospérité et la croissance économique
d'ailleurs plus que la prospérité vient
avec un quantum de déshumanisation
confronté à ce même choix aujourd'hui et
on le voit évidemment avec le
confinement dans une forme extrême mais
quand vous dites ces gens qui se
chargent au fond de réfléchir au monde
de demain à cet imaginaire à ce fantasme
de qui parlez-vous je pense que ces
dégâts fin je crois qu'en effet ce qui
est tout à fait extraordinaire
aujourd'hui c'est que quelques
entreprises qui vont émerger d'une
compétition darwinienne il y avait
beaucoup de candidats et peu d'élus à la
fin peut-être y en a d'autres qui
surgiront les netflix etc ne faisait pas
partie du trio de tête au départ et donc
le jeu n'est pas terminé mais ce qui est
certain c'est qu'il ya très très petit
nombre d'acteurs qui sont en train en
effet de définir le monde de demain et
la différence qui était pompier tente
c'est que avant peut-être d'une certaine
manière les innovations et des fêtes à
l'intérieur des entreprises des ouvriers
au fond on était à la recherche d'une
ergonomie mac optimale banc avec encore
une fois tout look top d'horreur que ça
a pu vouloir dire dans l'organisation du
monde de travail mais ça venait de
l'intérieur des entreprises cette
recherche d'efficacité
là ça vient vraiment en extériorité
c'est à dire apple réfléchit à des
google à toutes sortes de manières de
faire la médecine autrement ça ne vient
pas des médecins
ça ne vient pas des hôpitaux ça vient du
dehors donc c'est un monde proche de la
science fiction parce que c'est celui là
qui nourrit l'imaginaire deux de ses
acteurs de ces jeunes qui dans la
silicon valley cherche l'application
tueuse qui va remplacer les avocats qui
va remplacer les médecins qui va
remplacer les coachs sportifs qui vont
remplacer les agences de voyages voilà
c'est c'est là que tout l'imaginaire de
ces nouveaux inventeurs se situe et et
oui l'état est souvent à la remorque
à la traîne et moi je le regrette
profondément j'aimerais que ce soit les
hôpitaux que soient les enseignants qui
est la main sur ces nouvelles
technologies
c'est pas le cas aujourd'hui et pourtant
après s'être créé vous le dit très bien
on s'est rendu compte qu'il y avait des
métiers essentiels des indispensables
alors on pense à robotiser les
caissières on se rend compte de leur
rôle aussi fondamental dans le contact
à quel horizon vous vous situez ce
potentiel
cette potentielle numérisation du monde
cette nouvelle économie maire de crocs
et maintenant déjà que ça commence déjà
quand vous rentrez dans un bureau vous
avez presque toujours la même scène des
gens derrière un écran d'ordinateur ont
été inventé dans les années 80 donc on
était à la chaîne dans les années vingt
et un suivi dans la société industrielle
d'après guerre aujourd'hui on est en
ligne
donc c'est déjà le cas qu'on est alors
comment résister
d'ailleurs est-ce qu'il faut résister à
cette économie déshumanisante où tout se
fera distance je crois qu'il faut il
faut résister il faut faire advenir un
autre monde si c'est possible je disais
il faudrait que les hôpitaux et la main
sur cette technologie pour bien
optimiser le rapport entre patients et
le et le et le et le soignant en voyons
où sont les besoins et on comprend que
quand une fois que les technologies
peuvent aider à faire une chose mieux
mais mais sans jamais briser le lien
entre les deux je crois que les
enseignants aussi ont des nouvelles
technologies qui doivent pouvoir
utiliser peut-être pour changer la
manière dont il en scène mais
certainement pas pour casser le lien
entre les enseignants et les élèves et
beaucoup de choses et beaucoup de choses
comme ça donc il faut résister le
langage de mai 68 pour lutter contre la
société industrielle métro boulot dodo
etc
je pense reste valide on voyait qu'ils
avaient une critique profondément
humaniste du monde industriel des années
60 qui malgré toutes les promesses de
richesse était considéré par la jeunesse
des sixties les hippies aux états unis
où les gauchistes en france comme des
humains dix ans et on a armé en quelque
sorte une critique culturelle manistes
artistes du set
les sociologues du
mondiale il faut résister à ça il faut
résister à l'idée que tout se passe dans
les réseaux sociaux il faut résister à
l'idée que voilà on peut produire de
l'information sur ces réseaux sans
passer par des journalistes
il ya un petit travail un peu
corporatiste des différents métiers à
faire mais qui peut être révolutionnaire
se disait bourdieu il ya il ya quelques
temps être corporatiste par soi c'est
résister à la moulinette de l'histoire
dans le bon sens justement alors résisté
aux gaffes à vous l'avez dit ça c'est
pour les géants du numérique du privé
parce qu'il ya évidemment des vrais
problèmes de libertés publiques et on
l'a déjà vu avant avant cette crise avec
la circulation des données personnelles
des états eux-mêmes ont-ils d'ores et
déjà ses data est ce que les états eux
mêmes peuvent participer à cette
potentielle surveillance généralisée où
vous faites économique de numéro alors
ces secteurs un des effets j'espère pas
un mauvais de cette crise sanitaire
c'est vrai que quand on parlait dans un
ouvrage qui était publié l'année
dernière de capitalisme de surveillance
le point de départ de llanelli c'était
de dire on est dans une société de
surveillance mais à la différence des
régimes de surveillance anciens ce sont
des sociétés privées qui vous surveille
et pour pousser un peu le paradoxe la
surveillance des régimes totalitaires
c'était pour vous empêcher de vous
exprimer c'est un peu l'inversé
on a un capitaliste de surveillance mais
qui veut que vous exprimiez qu'il veut
que vous sortiez toutes vos lubies vos
fantasmes et c'est pour pouvoir
justement vous offrir des solutions à
tout ça vous rêvez d'être patron va vous
donner
donc c'était quelque chose de très
différent de l'idée qu'on avait des
sociétés totalitaires
même si elles le sont parce que c'est du
bio pouvoir pour parler comme michel
foucault à lyon vient vous chercher dans
les replis de votre intimité pour tout
savoir de vous maintenant avec la crise
sanitaire les états vont prendre la main
sur ces données aussi est un petit peu
un débat sur la question de savoir si
les applications qui vont permettre de
tracer les gens à proportion de leurs
contacts vont rester vraiment des
données privées dans les dents les dans
les portables ou si c'est un grand or
die
peur de l'état qui va permettre de me
surveiller les états comme la corée otc
l'état dans son grand serveur qui sait
ce que vous devenez ya une formule que
les gaffes a proposé il ya une alliance
apple google qui est celle avec laquelle
travaille l'état français pour avoir une
formule c'est dans votre portable
mais à ce moment là c'est le portable
c'est l'iphone qui allait donner donc
c'est les gars fin on a l'impression que
on n'a pas d'autre choix que l'état d'un
côté ou les gaffes à de l'autre pour ça
que je plaide pour une troisième voie
celle dans lequel ce serait les hôpitaux
qui aurait les données ce serait
beaucoup plus rassurant pour tout le
monde
je pense que c'est ça la voix que les
français préféreraient est-ce qu'ils en
sont capables
je crois hélas que non il faut choisir
entre cette alternative l'état central
pas les hôpitaux qui est à son crâne
avec le numéro de sécurité sociale etc
qui c'est tout c'est pas la garde mittal
qui va être le bon sport de ce monde où
on est bien sa patrie sans merci
beaucoup daniel cohen ça fait froid dans
le dos mais c'est passionnant
merci beaucoup et voilà le jour d'après
collection d'entretien thématiques à
retrouver sur la chaîne youtube dès le
cp insistait chef cette émission tout de
suite votre soirée documentaire avec le
jean pierre gratien à demain
[Musique]